hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory
today we're going to be diving deep into
the life of regulus octurus black also
known as RAB a character that may not be
particularly well known by those who
have only seen the films
you may recall him as the enigmatic
character whose Journey from loyalty to
Lord Voldemort to becoming a courageous
de Factor captured the hearts of fans
worldwide
today I'll be telling his compelling
story diving into the biography of one
of the Wizarding worlds unsung heroes
but first a brief introduction in the
realm of The Wizarding World the name
regulus black resonates with a sense of
mystery and Intrigue Born Into The Noble
House of black known for its complex
history and unwavering belief in pure
blood Supremacy regulus's Destiny seemed
predetermined however life often
presents unexpected paths and regulus's
journey would lead him down A Road Less
Traveled shrouded in the very Darkness
he sought to embrace regulus's Story
begins with the complex upbringing
biography
born in 1961 to Orion and all Burger
black regulus Arcturus blank grew up in
the esteemed House of black alongside
his elder brother Sirius he got the name
regulus from his great uncle and the
name Arcturus from his paternal
grandfather
the blacks were at one point one of the
most powerful Wizarding families in all
of Britain their family lineage can be
traced back through the centuries and
was at one time celebrated as one of the
proudest pure blood families in the
world but by the time regulus and his
brother Sirius were born only a few male
heirs remained and while their shared
bloodline connected them the respective
Journey's regulars and Sirius would take
them down vastly different parts
as far as physical appearance is
concerned regulus possessed the same
classic black family traits that set
them apart from others his dark hair
cascading and Sleek waves framed a face
that exuded an heir of enchanting
mistake the blacks known for their
esteemed bloodline and pride in their
pure blood Heritage were marked by sharp
and angular features regulus
encapsulated this aesthetic with defined
cheekbones and a strong jawline that
showcased his determination and
conviction
Beyond his physical attributes regulus
black possessed an inherent style that
reflected his Noble lineage he carried
himself with a Regal posture commanding
attention whenever he entered a room his
choice of attire often consisting of
tailored robes and ornate accessories
exemplified the refined taste and
impeccable standards of the black family
but while his appearance in style may
have aligned him with New Traditions and
expectations of the elite it was
regulus's internal transformation that
would truly set him apart growing up in
the prestigious black family regulus was
expected to embrace their pure blood
elitism and while his brother Sirius
rebelled against their family's
Traditions regulus was drawn to the
Allure of their Noble lineage dutifully
following in the footsteps of his
parents and other ancestors I hated a
lot of them my parents with their pure
blood Mania convinced that to be a black
made you practically Royal my Idiot
Brother soft enough to believe them
that's him he was younger than me and a
much better son as I was constantly
reminded
though Sirius was the older son and
official Heir the pair's parents much
preferred regulus Sirius fueled by a
burning desire for freedom and Justice
rejected the family's narrow-minded
views and broke free from their
expectations
by rejecting these ideals Sirius caused
a deep rupture within the family
The Divide between Sirius and his
parents only grew stronger when upon
beginning his studies at Hong courts he
was sorted into Gryffindor House regulus
on the other hand embraced the family's
beliefs and traditions earning the
approval of their parents this Bond
became even stronger when regulus upon
beginning his studies at Hogwarts were
sorted into Southern house and it was
within the hallowed Halls of Hogwarts at
regulus first began to develop into the
wizard he was destined to become
attending the school for roughly seven
years between 1972 and 1979. in addition
to his studies regulus became a Seeker
for the southern Quidditch team putting
his agility on display in Pursuit Of The
elusive golden snitch becoming a Death
Eater from a very early age regulus held
great admiration for Lord Voldemort and
dreamed of one day joining the ranks of
the Death Eaters his room which was
adorned with cutouts of Articles and
photographs from the daily Prophet
showcasing the dark lord and his
followers was a testament to his
fascination
beneath this was a collection of yellow
newspaper cuttings all stuck together to
make a ragged collage Hermione crossed
the room to examine them they're all
about Voldemort she said regular seems
to have been a fan for a few years
before he joined the Death Eaters
by the time he was 16 regulars had
become an official Death Eater and
received the infamous dark mark an
emblem of his allegiance to Voldemort
and his pursuit of pure blood Supremacy
surprisingly his family although never
having men Death Eaters themselves
shared similar beliefs and approved
irregulous embracing this path they saw
Voldemort as the champion of their cause
someone who sought to establish the
superiority of pure blood Wizards over
Muggles and when regulus aligned himself
with Lord Voldemort and joined the ranks
of the Death Eaters he entered a world
shrouded in secrecy Bound By An
unwavering commitment to the Dark Lord's
cause regulus became a pawn in
Voldemort's grand scheme a pawn tasked
with following orders and carrying out
acts of unspeakable horror he found
himself surrounded by a Motley Crew of
individuals each driven by their own
Twisted desires and unwavering loyalty
to their dark leader for most of the
people that regulars had become
affiliated with the Allure of power and
acceptance within this exclusive group
was enough to keep them firmly
entrenched in Voldemort's dark Embrace
however regulus Arcturus blank's journey
is a Death Eater and took a different
turn eventually taking a glimpse at the
true nature of called more terrain the
suffering inflicted upon innocent lives
and the corruption that fasted within
his ranks defecting as regular delved
deeper into the inner workings of the
Death Eaters his perspective began to
shift and By 1979 regulus had developed
serious reservations about his
allegiances to Voldemort and the Death
Eaters however in spite of his loss of
Faith regulus was still hesitant to take
any sort of action that is until one day
when Voldemort needed the assistance of
regulus's House of creature eager to
please his master regulus readily agreed
to creature helping him unaware of the
Fate that awaited his poor family's
servant unknown to regulus Voldemort
wanted to use creature to test the
defenses around his locket horcrux
Voldemort's intention was to leave the
house self to die
fortunately creature managed to escape
at which point he returned to his master
regulus recounting all of the gruesome
details it was at this point that
regulus truly became aware of
Voldemort's callousness and disregard
for those who Faithfully served him this
maltreatment of creature proved to be a
turning point for regulus it awakened
within him a sense of compassion and the
realization that the values he'd once
embraced were flawed In This Moment
regulus finally recognized the darkness
and cruelty that lay beneath the surface
of his grandiose Ambitions and so
regulus black embarked on the journey
that would shape not only his own
destiny but also the fate of The
Wizarding World
plot against Voldemort when reunited
with his loyal house elf creature the
depths of Voldemort's callous nature was
not the only thing he uncovered it was
in this moment that regulus also
uncovered the truth behind Voldemort's
immortality
how regulus came to the conclusion that
they lock it to horcrux tying Voldemort
to the Mortal realm is not clear but
what was clear to regulus is that the
cursed locket needed to be destroyed and
so with the steadfast determination to
destroy this Twisted remnant of the Dark
Lord's power regulus along with creature
devised a daring plan they would create
a replica of the locket destroy the rear
locket and leave the decoy in its place
this plan would ensure that Voldemort's
Warcraft says would not be entirely
unsusceptible to destruction with his
loyal companion creature by his side
regulus ventured into a treacherous cave
facing the perils that lay within he
brought along with him a replica of the
locket and of course his famous latter
into the dark lord I know I will be dead
long before you read this but I want you
to know that it was I who discovered
your secret I have stolen the real
horcrux
destroyed as soon as I can I face death
in the hope that when you meet your
match you'll be mortal once more r a b
but regulus's Mission came with one very
big sacrifice his life in order to reach
the horcrux he had to Brave the potion
that protected it a potion known as the
drink of Despair the potion in question
had a mysterious nature capable of
inducing intense Agony fear confusion
and an overwhelming thirst furthermore
the only way to dispel the potion was by
consuming it in its entirety this unique
characteristic indicated that the potion
was designed to safeguard something of
utmost significance and although the
potion typically did not result in death
it did leave the Drinker severely
weakened and vulnerable undoubtedly this
potion must act in a way that will
prevent me taking the horcrux it might
paralyze me cause me to forget what I'm
here for create so much pain I'm
distracted or render me incapable in
some other way this being the case Harry
it will be your job to make sure I keep
drinking even if you have to tip the
potion into my protesting mouth you
understand and so regular strike the
potion that protected the horcrux
sacrificing himself to allow creature to
complete their mission
the drink of Despair however was not the
only Safeguard protecting Voldemort's
horcrux in the cave containing the
locket there was also a lake a lake that
housed an army even Ferry controlled by
Lord Voldemort
and it wasn't the potion that caused
regulars to meet his demise but instead
the inferior who dragged the weakened
regulus to his death
before meeting his demise however
regulus gave creature a very specific
set of instructions one replace the rear
locket with the fake one two flee
without him three find a way to destroy
the horcrux and four never revealed the
truth to the black family despite the
dangerous circumstances creature was
able to obey his master's instructions
and switch the lockets before leaving
the island unfortunately however
creature was not able to destroy
Voldemort's locket Legacy in his final
Act regulus demonstrated the true
strength of character and the power of
one person to make a difference no
matter how small they may seem his
journey epitomizes the complexities of
family loyalty and the search for
Redemption born into a world of
privilege and entrenched beliefs
regulus's choices challenge the very
foundations upon which he was raised but
regulus's Legacy goes beyond his
contribution to the fight against
Voldemort he also much like his brother
was able to shatter the mold of a
typical black family member known for
their pure blood supremacism by
challenging his family's beliefs and
aligning himself with the good guys
regulars demonstrated the power of
individual conscience and the ability to
break free from the prejudices of one's
lineage
relationships now that we've got a good
sense of regular's black story I want
the next segue into some other elements
of his character particularly the
complicated nature of his various
relationships as well as the rationale
for why he was omitted from the movies
regulus didn't have many particularly
strong bonds in The Wizarding World this
is in large part due to the fact that he
defected against the group that he
previously aligned himself with however
if we were to consider the relationships
in regulus's life
I think the two most important ones are
Sirius and creature
regulus's relationship with Sirius was
strained right from the start and Sirius
being the eldest hoped that he could
protect regulars from the poisonous
influence of their family he wanted his
younger brother to have a chance at a
life outside the constraints of their
oppressive lineage regulus however
became swayed by the Allure of power
shed his parents belief in pure blood
Supremacy making him a favored son and
it was actually this shared ideology
that prompted him to join the Death
Eaters in the first place by embracing
the ideals of his parents regulus went
on to receive more and more validation
further casting a shadow over Sirius who
vehemently rejected the belief system
held by his family
with the two boys going down very
separate paths it was nearly impossible
for them to maintain any semblance of a
relationship regulus actively sought
validation from his parents by embracing
their ideals whereas Sirius disenchanted
with his family's values distanced
himself from the black family and its
ideology
it's entirely safe to say that two boys
simply never saw eye to eye however
despite their differences there are
indications of underlying love between
the brothers we get a glimpse of how
Sirius feels about his brother in the
Order of the Phoenix when Sirius
discusses his family and brother
analyzing the text closely Sirius seems
to discuss his family with pure contempt
he's disgusted by them on the other hand
when he discusses regulus his tone
shifts yeah he calls him his stupid
idiot brother but I think there's some
love there I think that the reminder of
his brother incites rage and serious not
because of what he was but instead the
poor decisions that he made I think that
serious sees regulars as a lost
opportunity a brother he could have been
close with that made all the wrong
decisions under his parents influence a
man that blindly sought validation and
power without ever truly thinking of the
consequences leave Cyrus small bitterly
and run a hand through his long unkempt
hair because I hated the whole lot of
them my parents with their pure blood
Mania convinced that to be a black made
you practically Royal
my Idiot Brother soft enough to believe
them that's him serious chapped a finger
at the very bottom of the tree the name
regulus black a date of death some 15
years previously followed the date of
birth
he was younger than me said Sirius and a
much better son as I was constantly
reminded but he died said Harry yeah
said Sirius stupid idiot he joined the
Death Eaters you're kidding it's clear
that Sirius blames regulus's bad
decisions on stupidity rather than
explicitly calling him a bad person
analyzing the way he speaks even further
I think that the pauses in his speech
speak volumes there are clearly things
that he wants to say that he leaves
unsaid which tells me that Sirius
impression of his brother is not
anything like how he sees the rest of
his family I think that the path that
regulus eventually went down proves that
there was a lot more of Sirius in him
than Sirius ever knew which could
perhaps suggest that had they gone down
a more similar path these two brothers
would have been incredibly close but
perhaps the most important and
simultaneously unlikely relationship in
regulus Black's life was with the black
family house elf creature as we know
creature was instrumental in helping
regulus defy Voldemort but I don't think
that what creature subjected himself to
would have been accessible to just any
black family member in truth future and
regulars shared a special bond the
relationship between regulus and
creature was formed within the black
family home where creatures served as a
traditional house elf for Generations
over the years regulus always treated
creature with immense kindness and
respect which ultimately fostered a deep
bond between them this type of behavior
stood in deep contrast to the typical
treatment of house elves by pure blood
families according to creature regulus
was extremely kind to him and the
Loyalty that regular showed creature
inspired Fierce devotion in return this
bond is evident in creatures unwavering
dedication to regulus even after his
master's death as seen in his role in
the locket horcrux Mission Omission from
the films regulus Black's character
contributes significantly to the
intricate tapestry of the Harry Potter
narrative his courage Redemption Arc and
sacrifice create a powerful contrast to
the story Central games of love and
friendship regulus's exploration of dark
magic and eventual turn against
Voldemort and depth and layers to The
Wizarding World but I felt that by
excluding regulars from the films a
vital piece of the story is left Untold
movie only fans denied the opportunity
to witness the complexities of regulus's
character and the lessons his journey
imparts the absence of his Redemption
and sacrifice robbed audiences of a
powerful and moving narrative thread But
ultimately I think it was the challenges
of translating a vast and intricate book
series into a limited movie format that
undoubtedly played a role in regulus's
Omission there was too much going on and
too much to cover which meant that
filmmakers had to prioritize Central
characters and story lines regulus's
character while significant in the books
may have been deemed Expendable with
regards to the film regulus
architecturus Black's absence from the
Harry Potter movies is undoubtedly felt
by fans who recognized the significance
of his character in the original series
his exclusion deprived us of a
Redemption story brimming with poignancy
and lessons and while the reasons for
his Omission may stem from The Challenge
of adapting the books and streamlining
The Narrative the impact is undeniable
regulus's presence would have added
another layer of richness and complexity
to the on-screen world we fell in love
with closing thoughts despite his
significant contributions to the
Wizarding World regulus's Legacy remains
largely unknown his story hidden in the
shadows is a testament to the many
unsung heroes who sacrifice themselves
for the greater good without the glory
or recognition that their deeds deserved
it is up to us the devoted fans to
ensure that regulus's Legacy is not
forgotten and that his name is honored
for his courageous acts as Sirius
himself once said we've all got both
light and dark inside us what matters is
the part we choose to act on that's who
we really are and that's it for this
video If you enjoyed the content please
like the video and subscribe to the
channel until next time remember it does
not do to dwell on dreams and forget to
live